we were having the debate all morning  what is the best Quentin Tarantino movie  you don't do you think like that do you  look back on your career and say this is  the defining movie of my life it's the  best I did you know for years people  used to ask me stuff like that and then  I would usually say something well  they're all like my children  then I would change it to well it kind  of depends on when you ask me if you ask  me one year or one moment I could say oh  Kill Bill another one I could say  something else but I really do think  once upon a time in Hollywood is my best  movie when you watch your own movies  back or I don't know if you do but yeah  when you you do yeah when when you um  why do you watch your own movies back I  love you you'll love them I love my  movies  everybody else is invited all right